by more it Singh from Georgia Tech and
it would be talking about our growing
strong subset selection and thanks for
showing up on in the body some of you
might be still groggy and thinking
whether I've come from the other program
huh
over here but yes I'll talk about some
diverse subjects elections and some
models some algorithms and some non
algorithms and hopefully with some see
some hyperbolic polynomials as well let
me start by a simple example the kind
and introduce you the problems actually
most of my talk I'll I'll actually talk
about particular applications of the
model that I go at do and and maybe one
or two algorithms I'll mention but the
most of the focus will be on like
introducing the model and telling you
what the applications are and there are
lots of problems and open problems
that'll also will Ord naturally come out
okay
good so yeah so the problem I want to
look at is try like is to collect we
find the subset from a big corpus which
is somewhat representative and and
diverse so like for example like I give
you I want to do an image search if
really want to just read one element
images these are the kind of images you
would like to pick but if I really want
to pick images which are more diverse as
well which kind of have different kind
of Jaguars in it in some sense right
like so that's the kind of thing I would
like and and these are the kind of
things we also decide let me do every
day and sometimes my computer as well
you give good like you can only give -
any questions - or in your exam and you
want to make sure the questions you are
giving are diverse and representative of
the whole subject that you do like and
sometimes like for example in in many of
these automated tested these are even
done online and depending on how your
performance have been so far and like
you are depending on that you will be
asked different sets of questions right
so we wanted to come up with some models
for many of these things and the which
are mathematically interesting as well
so one of the things that is like is
very nice model is using the terminal
point processes so where what you do is
assign a vector to each of your objects
for example image and this vector would
like would be some kind of a feature
vector so it's somewhat representative
of the image in some sense in some high
dimension r2 ready and then you say okay
I'll I want to pick a set of images and
a set of images I will pick I want to
pick vectors which are in some sense
long which are useful which have good
features but also are not pointing in
the same direction so what I will do is
try to pick the set of vectors which
maximize the volume of the panel of the
pitch my idea so in some sense I want
them to be orthogonal as well as long so
maximize the volume on the palette open
like them and wheel and this problem has
been actually quite interesting I will
talk bit more detail about it we might
have some weight some gradient of this
problem also earlier in the workshop
I'll like talk about cardinality and
partition constraints in this talk I
won't you I will use a word Metroid but
it really doesn't matter if you don't
know it will just say I'll define what
partition castrates are formally and
that's what we will be enough for us so
good so and of course determinant or so
the volume can be represented by the
oh of this parlor puppet and more
generally what are the more general
model I look at is the following model
I'm going to embed each item in some
vector in R to the D and as a vector V I
I will get so for every item in my
corpus think of these images and our
goal will be to pick a subset s and once
you pick a subset s I would actually
evaluate how good or bad it is by a
function which typically will be a
spectral function and of this particular
matrix and we'll see why did I figure
like for now let's assume that's what we
do and I try to justify why this is a
good function to pick I'm going to
minimize some spectral function of this
sum of rank one matrices of VI VI
transpose inverse of this matrix of
course I could have written the function
of this matrix as well like okay it
doesn't matter but writing in terms of
inverse it's quite nice and the kind of
functions we will look at the most
natural functions their determinant or
the trace and respect to law these are
the three functions but of course you
can ask for any other spectral function
as well but each of them actually have
will have combinatorial meanings and
people have studied them in many
different areas and we'll see some of
them as well so what are my collection
see we look at a bunch of constraints
for them the simplest one would be maybe
a carnality constraint I want to pick a
subset of Scarn ality cake okay fun good
yes
so we will yes so we will look at cases
one kay yeah and I guess that's what
used to be these are not landed
questions yeah so okay let's go slowly
you say one that's one the constraints
you look at the are mostly carnality
constraints here the algorithmically v i
would want to say things are much better
understood we will also look at
partition constraints partition
constraints are my ground set will be
partition into maybe a bunch of paths
and from each part i tell you how many
to pick okay like of course more general
these are made troy this is a Metroid
basis of am a trial you cannot even look
at more general ability matrix and some
of the theory generalizes some of them
doesn't and some of them is generalizing
as I speak I believe right so with a lot
of the new developments that we have
heard about in this workshop but mostly
in the stock and free focus on
cardinality and partitioning states
okay and as we mentioned we have to be
careful with inverse of a matrix so if K
is bigger than D okay if k k is a set
number of vectors I will pick if that
number of vectors I'm go picking a more
than D then things will be fine I would
expect this matrix you should be picking
linearly independent vectors I should
want you to enforce that this will be
invertible matrix if K is less than D
then I'm only it's a rank K matrix at
most so I should not expect to have an
inverse but in some sense I will put it
on there laughs but in some sense when
you generalize all of these concepts in
terms of elementary symmetric
polynomials or their ratios and so on
okay so that's what we'll focus on
basically just ignore the zero eigen
values right if you're picking K ignore
D minus k zero eigen values and after
that you like take four determinants
take the product for trace take the sum
and so on that's the problem B so let's
see some existing so let me take one
problem so actually before let me just
beef you tell you the outline most of
time I'll talk about some application of
these models then I'll talk about
approaches for the cardinality
constraints and I would say here we
understand the algorithm equations lot
better and they're both approaches based
on convex program convex programming
approaches as well as combinatorial
algorithms actually and one uses them
they work differently in practice and in
theory as well and we will see some of
those results approaches of partition
constraints and more metal consensus
more complicated but here this is where
I would say from this workshops point of
view things retain stable polynomials
play a crucial role in trying to
understand how well can you approximate
these problems so results by Gurewitz
on permanent and the results bamako
Speedman silver so on Carson C mere
conjecture naturally fit it in this
framework and can be utilized to solve
these optimization problems and we see
some of those and as I said some of
these results are and can be generalized
to matrix using all matrices using the
machinery of completely locked form 10-k
polynomials some not clear yet the other
issue over for general partition concern
will is from that most of these reserve
will be non algorithmic at least okay
some of them might be algorithmic but
mostly they are non algorithmic which is
a concern as well
we'll discuss that in more detail okay
so let me talk mainly about the
application right now just to understand
what is this abstract model capture
right so so what how what are these
vectors like how what can I represent
with them and what these functions
really mean right and convince those
things good so let's take the problem or
experimental design a statistic so
what's this was a set up I have some
unknown theta star in art already which
I want to measure okay I do I have I
don't know what this thing is what I can
do is take a bunch of linear
measurements for it so I can take a
linear measurements I can pick at one
vector v1 through VN these are also
vectors in R to the D I can take if I
take a measurement with respect to V I I
get V I in a power beta star but every
time I do I also get some noise okay
that's my output Y I and we assume for
simplicity the noise is actually a
Gaussian with mean zero so and various
Delta so you can take a bunch of linear
measurements these are the possible
linear measurement you can take and the
goal is to [ __ ] of these leaves your
measurement should I do in statistics is
called the experimental design problem
which of the out of the n experiments
which K I need to do the point is okay
suppose I do a bunch of experiments
let's say I do set s of experiments then
I need to si what my goal is to estimate
say Stata star how am I going to
estimate the theta star because
everything is quite linear so in that
that problem is very nicely understood
what you want to do is is basically do a
least square problem that will be a most
likelihood estimator as well so what you
want to do is just put the put all these
vectors which for which you take the
take the measurements put them in a
matrix as rows and just basically find
out the least square estimator the least
square estimator you can exactly write
down and you can check what the error is
of course the error will depend on which
measurements you did right and then the
error will also be a Gaussian this will
be like a D dimensional Gaussian vector
whose mean will be zero but its
covariance matrix will be exactly that
matrix we wrote down basically summation
of Vav transpose inverse over all the
rank one matrices for which you took
experiments this is a simple calculation
it's like yeah it's a nice square one
can't exactly write it down that's what
it is and of course this is my error so
basically I could think of this is my
theta star my
stimate like would be like in some sense
expect it to be somewhere in this
confidence ellipsoid lipstick responding
to this covariance matrix right and what
I would like to have is a good
confidence I would like this ellipsoid
to be small like that's what I would
like I would like well small in the
sense what is my choice my choice is
what experiments I picked I want the
experiments that I pick to make sure
this ellipsoid is as small as possible
and of course this is a lector ellipsoid
so I have to put some norm on it of
course one natural thing is to make sure
I minimize the volume of this ellipsoid
right that's exactly like minimizing the
determinant of this inverse because in
this case actually things make sense
when K is bigger than DL so I assume
this method is going to be invertible so
which is equal and to maximizing the
determinant of the sum of these four
matrices so this is the case when K is
bigger than D if K is the D or less than
equal to D and if you kind of generalize
the determinant by the element tastes
like a lemon pretty symmetric problem
and this is exactly equivalent to the
volume of the parallelepiped as well
okay just think of the case when K equal
to D okay this will be exactly the
volume square of the palapa pen so
that's this is this model actually
generalizes both of those things very
naturally
you could also say okay hey maybe I want
to minimize the average error that I
have in my vector which is equivalent to
saying the expected norm of this vector
which would be exactly trying to
minimize the trace of this covariance
matrix what will be my expected length
of the error that I will get in my
estimate it will also say maybe I
minimize the maximum radius among all
directions which would be which is
called like these are actually in
statistics they have this alphabet soup
right it's called D optimality a
optimality is for average I believe
these four determinant and a optimality
this will be you are minimizing the
variance maximum variance in every
direction so maximum minimizing the
maximum eigen value of this matrix this
matrix good and of course these are not
you can actually ask for other
optimality criteria there are a whole
set in people so this is look at B for
us I will not do and there's a lot of
work in in in statistic designing
algorithms trying to come more general
models and so on but that's not a
direction will go you try to just take
this simple in your model and try to
understand how well what are the
algorithms for it and can you actually
prove some guarantees about them mostly
we'll be concentrating on approximation
algorithm trying to prove some
worst-case guarantees okay so recall
this was the more general problem model
that I just said and the problems
already discussed with this model for a
different these functions F and so far I
just focused there the problems focus on
the cardinality constraints for modular
constraint system okay so let me
actually talk about some more problems
when these vectors are special vectors
and for those for us but the most
special nicest vectors are then with
these vectors corresponds to from come
from grass okay
so I like yeah so the set up would be I
give you a graph and for every edge I
introduce a vector in the R to the V
which will be basically the I just
orient the graph in arbitrary way and I
just take the indicator vector for that
vertex for the head - the tail okay so
that's D - ahead I would just guess what
I will do and I then this matrix the sum
of the rank one it is exactly the
laplacian and then I could ask myself
okay what are those corresponding
objectives and what those those problems
that we wrote down what do they mean
over here and it turns out those are the
problems people have looked at very
closely as well over the years so for
example you can look at a determiner of
this matrix well this is not a full rank
matrix have to be careful again the
laplacian
right is always this issue but let's
let's put it on the rack basically it is
it just counts a number of spanning
trees in the graph it's exactly the
number of asperities go back to
Kirchhoff and so the problem of picking
K like so this problem that we wrote
down earlier is exactly the following
problem I give you a graph with some
number of edges and I want to pick K of
them and our goal will be to maximize
the number of spanning trees among the
sub graph that I found and these
problems have been looked earlier this
is a special case when F is it
there's another very interesting special
case which also wrote which is for the
men instead of a determinant I'll go to
the trace so trace of this matrix so
again this is not invertible I'll have
to be careful I will take the
pseudo-inverse or just ignore the zero
eigenvalue it turns out actually it is
really proportional to the average
effective resistance of the graph okay
and what is the effective resistance
effective resistance is a measure of
connectivity how well for any pair or
the effective resistance between them is
a measure of how well they are connected
it's basically the l2 square norm of the
unit flow if I serve or to send a unit
flow from I to J what's a minimum energy
I will minimum energy flow that I will
have and the energy of that flow and the
energy of the flow is basically the l2
square norm of the flow that I will have
and the nice thing is this kind of
nicely interpolates between edge
connectivity and shortest path if this
norm was one norm I want to find a unit
flow which has the minimum one norm
that's exactly the shortest path
distance between I and J and if this was
an infinity norm I write infinity norm I
want really send flow as on as splited
as much as possible that's really would
be the one over the edge connectivity
between this pair right if there are
like K disjoint paths between I and J
this would be exactly for the Infinity
norm will be 1 over K or squared over 2
ponyo so in some sense to nom nicely
interpolates between those things will
be small when you have many short edge
disjoint paths intuitively between any
two pair so I write the the problem that
we formulated earlier to minimize it
like trying to pick K of these edges to
minimize the effective resistance that's
what the problem we would have
formulated
right so five given a graph and select
gauges to minimize the average effective
resistance right it's a very natural
connectivity problem Network design
problem and this also been started in
literature as well and this is really
the special case of our problem when F
is defined to be the trace where you
have to be like appropriately overloaded
term placed because there's one
eigenvalue zero let's just ignore that
good and of course you can think of a
special case fsz the spectral norm as
well and that's very close related to
findings pacifiers in my graph as well I
won't go into detail although but the
results related to this are actually
quite useful for for the moles unit
problem as well okay so let me now move
on to trying to tell you what are the
approaches for the cardinality
constraints so there are quite a few
approaches that can be applied and that
give results for depending on the
different parameters that we have more
mostly the number of vectors you are
picking and the dimension those two
parameters play the most important role
how well you can actually solve these
problems I must mention all of these
problems are actually np-hard and those
reductions are are not very difficult
so more all of these so we really will
be focusing on approximation algorithms
so the first set of approach is to use a
convex programming approach so you write
a convex relaxation and the first
national convex relaxation is almost
straight forward to write nema as
represented some variant of that so let
me just do it actually special
specialize it for D design where I want
to minimize the determinant of the
inverse or equivalently maximize the
determinant because this is a
determinant of a D by D matrix so right
scaling is to actually take the D at
root of this determinant in some sense
that tells you the right scaling of this
number so that's what we are going to do
and of course you can write the most
natural comix relaxation why I introduce
a binary variable for every vector
whether I pick it in my set or not and
of course then I relax it to say that I
only put in upper and lower bounds to
have to be able to efficiently solve it
and I can write my objective in terms of
these variables that's the first
relaxation one would write most natural
relaxation for this problem and it turns
out actually this relaxation is pretty
good for Karait case actually it's there
are many different
algorithmic approaches really there was
a series of work actually going back
because this as I said it's very related
to computing finding the maximum volume
parallelepiped and also like similarly
simplex so this it goes back to a whole
work of Kassian and there have been a
series of works since then but really
culminated in this nice work by niccolò
who gave an approximation when K is at
mostly when a number of vectors you're
picking is at most D well of course
again you have to be made careful when K
is strictly in SMD you have to kind of
overload this determinant operator later
on we improved the result when K is
bigger than D you can actually the whole
result generalizes also smoothly you get
a of proximation the algorithms are
similar but the analysis need more work
one nice thing which was noticed by in
this very nice paper by Alonzo at all we
said that basically as K becomes much
large and at a dimension the problems
get simpler and simpler so in particular
when K is something like DL epsilon
square you can start getting 1 plus
epsilon approximation so I think that's
something like if there's one fact about
this problem from our as my perspective
keep in mind is this not as a the number
of vectors that you're picking it grows
large right the problem gets simpler and
simpler and they actually build the
these results build on methods based on
bus and speed massive on grass
pacification basically those are the
outcome that did generalize and these
results generalize actually essentially
for a large large class of these
functions have not just for the
determinant for many of them as well so
one of the things that we ask is whether
this like the dependence on epsilon is
is tight or not and it turns out that
depends on which F you pick okay so for
example in
dredge work with the G and also with
Sasha one town who's also sitting here
we showed basically as for D in
particular you can get a 1 plus epsilon
approximation where K is about D or
epsilon plus 1 over epsilon square so to
some extent the at least the in at least
in this result they dependence on
epsilon is still 1 over epsilon square
but it's only in the additive sense not
in the modular key reasons and all of
these results really rely on solving
this convex program and using the
solution to the furnace program which
would be fractional and trying to come
up with the rounding algorithm trying to
convert it into integer solution by
doing some sampling algorithm
or trying to even come deterministic
algorithms and so on so all of these
approaches a lot on that yes so good so
hardness so good so when K is at most D
then you can it's a px hard so you
cannot get a 1 plus epsilon
approximation so this e is a constant
but you cannot take it to 1 probability
1 plus epsilon so there is 1 like 1
point 0 1 or whatever like you cannot
get better than that but it's not E and
I don't need so use the right answer
either but that's what we have so far so
yeah good nice thing is actually is in
my department a bunch of statistics as
well and then you go talk to them and
tell them these are nice like the
problem that you have and they use this
and like you can give them these nice
rounding algorithms in yards and why do
you use something like this and they say
no what they use is simple local search
yeah which is what they call actually
the Fredo vaccine method given by
federal but it's really a simple local
search algorithm and that that's the
first if I tell you the design
accommodate allow algorithm it might be
if not the first a second one first
might be greedy but the second one will
certainly be local search alright and so
what is the algorithm of course right
like you want to pick 3 vectors so I'll
start with any set and if you can find a
swap you swap it as long as you
improving your objective so yeah if I
can exchange them I keep improving and
then I just keep doing it and it was
great in practice right and now of
course there are always issues with
running time of local search because how
many iterations does it take but in some
sense that really doesn't matter you
could say you only make improvement if
you make a enough improvement so then
you have to argue about me or local
search optimization so one of the work
that we recently did was just try to
understand these local search algorithms
as one for these objectives and the nice
thing is a very simple to implement they
are implemented actually in once a month
of the software's as well like sass and
other surface and but they are not
complained by any theoretical analysis
wide like why do they think they were
and it turns out actually one result we
just showed is again with tau sitting
here and Vivek Madonna and Z is that any
local optimal solution for at least for
D optimal actually is a 1 plus epsilon
where K is at least D plus D or epsilon
it terms this is a much better
dependence than
actually the previous dependencies we
saw using these rounding algorithms but
it turns out actually there is a reason
they are actually using these local
search algorithms they work really
really well at least here it even in the
worst case and in any local optimal
solution will be a 1 plus epsilon
approximation as long as K is actually
the the wide does it to convince
actually even the reason this works the
way we show it is actually why a convex
relaxations ok so what we show is using
a primal dual approach so we of course
don't solve it algorithm is the local
search algorithm how do we show this
result what I'm going to show you you
give me a local optimum solution I want
to show you it is good what I'm going to
do is exhibit you a dual of objective
within 1 plus Epsilon
ok and that will show you think of from
the number line right and I write this
is my convex programming op optimum
write the integral optimum is somewhere
below right and our local optimum is
even below that one right like this is I
guess 0 to infinity right whatever right
I'm my objective is increasing in that
direction I'm maximizing this is my
determinant local optimum is somewhere
over here so what the way we show it is
basically all the dual feasible
solutions are somewhere on this line
right this is the mid like dual is a
minimization problem this is the optimum
convex program the strong duality all
the feasible duals are somewhere over
here I'll just show basically a feasible
dual using your local optima give me a
local optimum using the local optimum I
will construct your feasible dual such
that this ratio is no more than 1 plus
Epsilon all right as long as K is bigger
so and that that will basically show all
of these ratios are no more than 1 plus
Epsilon
and yes yeah it's the same phonics
program so it's really all the local
search intuitively of course there could
be other reasons why it's working but
theoretically we can prove it why it
works is basically still does it somehow
in the wrong case so no actually yes
maybe I removed a few slides about it as
well so you can actually yeah so you
should be able to prove a better bound
it's these are our bounds you prove it's
not that they are tight the right answer
should be the same we just don't have
the right around in our system or
actually we have a class of rounding
algorithms I didn't sometimes it's a
which I remove because I wanted to like
our the other part as well but yes there
should be better rounding algorithm we
just don't know what they are
so yeah so basically uh so the even the
proof of this a very combinatorial
statement and this is quite like if like
the technique is quite standard in
approximation algorithms called dual
fitting right you're trying to fit a
dual to your primal solution although
which has no idea what the convex
program is but it's just a method of
analysis and it turns out even if
actually if you code it up and and the
time to solve it founders program and
that's really the bottleneck in almost
even do a lot of these algorithms when
the rounding algorithms are usually very
fast but solving the convex program
takes a lot of time and that's one of
the reasons why they use these simple
combinatorial algorithms because
determinants and so on these are not
very nice objectives for convex programs
to deal with so yeah similar but weaker
results also hold for the other
objective of trees as well so where the
dependence in epsilon is not as good as
the convex programming bound and so on
and you have to do some pre-processing
like they hold only yeah some people are
sensor is one but yeah like the spirit
of the statements is still that you
local search algorithms asymptotically
perform very well okay so in the last
10-15 minutes I just want to briefly
touch on partition restraints as well
and where we will see why are naturally
stable polynomials actually will show up
when we try to write try to like get
some good algorithms for these problems
and try to give you some idea why do
they naturally show up actually okay so
partition consists actually yeah of
course you could do more general metric
answers as well but partition chances
are quite nice and I'll before going to
the result I want to just give you one
very nice reduction where partition
constraints although they are not
explicitly there in the problem but in
them you can model your problem as with
partition constraints and that's
typically the the I would say the most
natural application of partition
constraints and which are in allocation
problems so right so this is a problem
which NIEM also talked about but I just
wanted to briefly mention it again just
to show you this reduction between
allocation problems and partition
constraints okay so what is the problem
sorting of any allocation problem so
here we are taking a problem where the
input is some n players I have n players
mmm items so number of items is more
and each player has a certain value for
each item so Vij I is the value that I
play right at the C's for if I give him
item G and what I want to find is
assignment I want to assign these all
the items to these players and you can
ask what is my objective you can have
multiple objectives that are you and one
is actually the Santa Claus maybe look
at the Santa Claus problem so Santa
Claus actually wants to make sure that
the least happy kid is as happy as
possible because he cares about the
least happy you want to make all the
kids very happy so what you want to do
is you want to maximize I lost a min
over here so this should be maximized
over all Sigma there should be a min
over I over here which I've lost some
minimum over all players the the the
happiness of a kid which are happiness
of the kid for him is a we are assuming
at it evaluation if I give him a bundle
he'll the kid will it's just some of the
values for the items he's received that
will be due this is the valuation of the
ayat kid and we have to uh we should
have a midni overheads I'm summing over
all J such that Sigma J equal Y thank
you yes this I should just added last
night which I guess I should have
solution yeah yes also in the previous
one okay both of these yes so basically
these are this will be the bunch set
those values of the bundle that was
assigned to the ia place so it should be
Sigma J equal Y and the social welfare
we look at the geometric mean okay
rather than this if you look at the sum
that's trivial and just assign the item
to the player who values is the most
right but we're really the make sure
that be I want to assign items who to
the place who value them as well as
every player should get something and
natural sure welfare seems to do that
Santa Claus fight to go for the worst
player at all so both of these problems
actually can be modeled in our model bit
partition constraints okay so I just
wanted to briefly just tell you how that
reduction goes and we will talk about
some algorithms so what we do is
basically we will introduce one vector
for each pair okay for each item and
each player I'm going to introduce a
vector u IJ the vector u IJ will be
basically will have only one nonzero
coordinate will be D so this vector will
be in the RM where they are n players so
will be right okay so it's a vector in
the player
dimension and it'll be basically square
root because of the scaling purposes
will be the square root of the value of
this item for this player and it turns
out if you assume this then if you
calculate our function on the
corresponding matrices without wrote
earlier for determinant we get this
natural shell fan and for Santa Claus is
really the spectral norm for the
diagonal matrices right it's I'm really
looking at the the spectral norm of the
inverse as really the minimum entry
right that's really what I'm going after
in some sense a good and then we will
also work about how do we introduce a
partition constraint is that for each
item each for each of my items I will
introduce a partition constraint of all
the vectors associated that you can only
pick one of of one of them because I can
assign each item only to one of the
plans so each item has one okay maybe I
should have a picture somewhere so but
these are my items so these are my
evaluations right so for this for this
item and person pair I have a vector
which is this one and for this one I
also have another vector which is this
one because for the second pair is the
value is five and because this item can
only go to this one or this one I'll say
okay among these two vectors you can
only pick one of them in your solution
among these two vectors you can only
pick one of them among these two vectors
you can only pick one of them and once
you pick those you actually put it in a
framework actually for the determinant
will become exactly the national shelf a
problem and for the santa claus and
become of like yeah for the spectrum
will become the santa claus ball and
both of these problems had be very well
studied both natural welfare as well as
santa cause problem over the years but
because it is naturally fit in a
framework that actually allows us to get
a bunch of results if you can solve our
problem for partition constraints okay
so so let me just briefly mention you
result that i this is a show that
actually they'll be for the maximum
determinant so that for determinant
objective for the more general partition
contained you can always get a 1 over
here proximation
a bunch of partitions there in the
partition we were picking just one one
vector but you can generalize it more
generally you pick bi and I want to pick
a basis such that I maximize my
determinant or minimize inverse of the
determinant of course I take the
appropriate root and that's what you get
so okay we have about ten minutes okay
good so I'll basically tell you a
polynomial relaxation in some sense it's
bit I feel it's slightly easier to
understand in this like of course
there's a general machinery of using
like lock and key polynomials and so on
which also like generalize it may some
of many of these things but it's cleaner
to just see how the phenomenal oxygen
comes up and what's really is going on
okay so let's try to write down or
convex relaxation the first one you
write down you say okay I'll try to
generalize what we had earlier we had a
relaxation for cardinality constrain why
don't I just write generalize that right
because I'll just change my constraints
so rather than writing out the
constraints on X that you pick K of them
I'll say from each partition you pick as
many you are supposed to pick that I'll
pick bi number vectors from partition P
I that's a number that's a constraint
I'll pick and each axis between zero one
objective I can still write it in terms
of our old objective for simplicity I've
just got rid of this the roots and so on
one over ba through one problem with
this is actually this cannot detect the
answer is zero versus nonzero and if you
think for a moment in this allocation
problem the answer 0 is non zero
actually is a very simple it's a
matching problem okay if I want to check
out whether let's say can I assign items
to players such that any of these
objective national shall welfare or or
the the Santa Clause objective is non
zero that can only happen if every
player can get an item with who he
values it as a non zero value so what I
should just look at is a support graph
of the non zero values right and check
whether there is a matching which covers
all the players if the answer is by part
like which is which you can just solve
it bipartite matching problem if the
answer is yes yes then if there is such
a dancer is non zero if there's no
dancer is zero right so that you can
detect in polynomial time and the
problem is this convex program cannot do
that so it can even return you a non
zero answer although the right answer
would be zero
and how do you now alleviate this
problem is basically you stand in this
convex program and what you do is do a
scaling kind of a thing which is quite
like common and matrix scaling kind of
approaches and so on so what you do good
so you get what I do is actually I'll
introduce a new variable ye which you
should think of is basically I'm scaling
the item e or like or vector e for
myself okay so of course
maybe I'll scale down some of the
valuations for someplace like this of
course you can't allow myself to do an
arbitrary scaling because then you just
drive down the objective to zero I want
to make sure I do such a scaling that my
integral optimum does not change but my
fractional optimum fractional solutions
objective need naturally goes down okay
that's the kind of scaling so how do I
ensure that like constraints on P would
be still the same but this constraint on
my scalings that I will do is that if I
look at the product of the scaling for
every feasible solution that remains
that is equal to 1 and if you insure
this then it's not very hard to see and
we will quickly see it as well then for
every integer solution I'm doing such a
scaling and I'm here I'm using really
the fact the determinate is a polynomial
can be expressed as a polynomial that
for every integer solution the objective
does not change but by doing this
scaling my actually I get it was a
minimizing over all possible scalings my
objective actually for the convex
program would go down and then it would
be able to date 0 vs. not so yeah and it
can't do that so let's see firstly of
course the question is how do I solve
this that's not very hard to see this
function is actually in X its lock and K
that we know but in Latin Y but in love
Y is actually la convex which is great
for us because our constraints are
actually linear in log Y so actually you
can solve this polynomial optimization
problem right actually I really want to
think of displace a polynomial
optimization problem it's a polynomial
in both x and y but in X this function
is locked on K so the determinant is not
concave but in log Y the function is
actually locked convex because all the
coefficients are non-negative so it's
also a special case and why these are
what is also called geometry programs
so why is this a relaxation so which has
our son like basically I'm saying for
every integer solution if I the
objective that will come out of it will
will be still larger than India solution
if I if I set X to be the integer still
indicate a vector for the integer
solution my doesn't matter what Y you
will pick I still get the value of the
integer solution okay let's verify that
so let B be optimal basis of the optimal
answer
so of course optimal value is the
determinant of just summation VV
transpose overall which I denote by L BB
so X star is just indicate a vector like
this thing so if F X star Y doesn't
matter what Y you pick in X star will
become 0 or 1 right so I'll just
restrict myself to the one vectors which
are vectors in B ye x VV transpose for
simplicity over here I'm assuming
actually that the size of the base is
exactly the D which is the set of the
dimension this so this this as a
polynomial in Y this is in each ye this
is a linear polynomial because these are
Antoine matrices and this is a degree D
polynomial and they are d of these terms
so it will become exactly Y to the B
times this objective and my constraint
by placing on Q is exactly this is one
so this is a relaxation and of course
like it might look like magic but these
are kind of things which are also using
matrix scaling and so on that's really
the approaches to get stronger
relaxations as well for over there as
well to let's say for approximating the
permanent and it turns out actually
algorithmic like I'll use from simple
algorithms where like in equality some
of which come out of matrix killing can
also be used for these problems to get
analyze the algorithms so what is the
algorithm algorithm is actually very
simple one okay and what you just think
like solid stone relaxation you ignore
why you just look at X X fractionally a
science youpix is right amount of
vectors from each partition you just
think of those as probability
distributions by after scaling so if you
pick bi elements I scale from Part I I
just scale the fraction solution by bi
in that path and I know I have a
probability distribution I sample bi x
from the distribution yeah
if used by the set Q so that mean that
every Y will be every Y you will be so Y
if that's a piece one possible solution
but that's not necessary
no so if for example what you can show
in the partition constraints all the Y
variables for all the elements in the
same partition how to be tried in this
matching case I have variables on the
edges right like edges are my very
vectors right of my graph so all the
edges incident at a particular vertex on
one side will be the same but of that
nature you can buy my exchanges yes
except you should have connectivity in
the space which you don't have actually
in this particular so you can okay so
you can partition oh yeah those are kind
of things you also use for analysis and
that but yes but actually what you
really need is overhead is greater than
equal to one overhead because for the
like I just want this for the relaxation
I just need to be grading with one but
for this particular partition contains
equality one also you can enforce which
is a weaker relaxation but still box yes
I have a lot of constraints but like of
course in queue
I really firstly ever have to do this
very change of variables I go to log of
Y then these are basically done this is
the linear constraints or all basis and
then they says you can optimize because
you can separate separation over them is
just a minimum weight basis in my weight
right yes good so the algorithm is the
first algorithm you would do randomized
rounding I scale it and I just do enough
for for in passes so how do I analyze it
the way to analyze it is basically now
go back to this polynomial I basically
where a plug in top put in the in my
objective the integral
what sorry the optimum fractional
solution for X 1 X bar Y I don't know
right why I'm optimized over like taking
a minimum over all such scalings but I
now look think of it actually as a
polynomial in Y again and I like expand
it out and have certain coefficients
like if maybe this should be a D I've
seen geing between B and a but this will
be a like a degree D polynomial or
degree our polynomial if these were our
by our matrices and if I just look at
what it is op star is actually just
optimization problem with this
polynomial it's a minimum of py overall
scalings right because outer problem X
bar I fixed it's what my optimum
fractional solution is exactly this one
ok and what is the expected value of the
algorithm you can try to write down what
it is the expansion actually it turns
out is just a collection like up up to a
scaling is some of bunch of the
coefficients of this polynomial in
particular those in the polynomial will
be all the multilinear terms for these
life which corresponds to the basis of
my I just look at the the coefficients
which corresponds to not all subsets
because here I've all subsets of the
particular size but those are not all
feasible because they don't satisfy
partition constraints I only look at the
terms which corresponds to which satisfy
the partition constraints that's my
objective actually so I have to relate
these two and basically what we show is
that this is not like this polynomial
like yeah this is very special but you
can actually prove any quality we want
to show this as large as compared to
this one right are some a bunch of
coefficients as large as compared to
minimizing or a certain optimization or
the problem will but we show this holds
for more general class of real stable
performance so the inequality and this
really relies on generalizes the result
of Gurewitz which basically showed
exactly such a thing when the metroid
was very very special in some sense
that's all one way to think about and
you get this right kind of things ok the
details are not really but like more
like a lot of these things have been
generalized as I mentioned as well so
you can also like improve it to national
welfare with Mema talked about we can
get the same kind of bounds for national
welfare as well later a Marian Quran and
also star Jack in which no engine rises
to larger class of Metroid's and at
least Lakia and almost all the Metroid's
you can get using the much
completely local omits for the
determinant objective right the heavy
look the determinant objective and
partition constrains I'm almost running
out of time so let me briefly mention to
you some the other objective that we are
looking at which was the e design like
which is the maximizing the minimum
eigen value of the matrix which is
equalent to minimizing the maximum eigen
value of the inverse right so I just and
again again under the partition
constraints and here again I want to
just tell you that the Machine you're
stable promise naturally comes up again
or sum of a partition constraints or
general maîtrise they naturally come up
as well so so what is the problem I give
you bunch of these vectors and a bunch
of partitions for simplicity just assume
I'm going to pick one one vector from
each part and I want to make sure I look
at the natives that we found I want to
make I want to maximize the minimum
eigen value of it of this matrix which
is same as minimizing the maximum value
of the inverse so what we can show this
is result with the Vivek and a show and
now sitting here is that you can write a
natural relaxation again like which is
the first luxation you will write it's
integrality gap is actually at most 1
plus epsilon if all the vectors are
small small compared to the optimal
objective which is a slightly viewed
condition but I said that you will see
this is not such a this is a natural
condition which is used in many like you
might have seen earlier is there is a
very nice result where Marcus Whitman
Rostow which says the following if a
bunch of lettuces a bunch of random
vectors whose sum them to identity right
and all these vectors are actually small
then I can pick one one like I there is
instantiation of these vectors such that
the maximum eigen value will be not too
large and it turns out our result is in
a very similar flavor except we have to
maximize the minimum eigen value this is
minimizing the maximum eigen value okay
so one has to actually go through the
proof and most of the proof generalizes
some part do not which we have to change
so what the main lemma be sure
essentially under the sim similar
assumptions you can also prove that the
minimum eigen value will also be very
close or to one there is an
instantiation
minimizing value and this lemma
essentially implies after a simple
reduction dabrander does distribution
come in when the distribution comes in
from the solution of the convex
relaxation it will be for each part I
will have a distribution because I have
to pick one vector so of course I can't
my fractional solution will pick
fractionally which is really a
probability distribution and really how
do these proofs so go by really they
really use stable promise and
interlacing in it the part where we have
to modify the previous arguments are
these multivariate barrier arguments in
it which means some careful changes so
that the proofs can go through where we
are looking for trying to maximize the
minimum eigen value but just I would say
in likea so these are with us in
progress the clarity what we have so far
is is not that much and something we are
trying to work out what happens in the
general case and so on I don't know B
let me see completely sure B then I know
there are results at least in the in the
spectres pass crap it can get both sided
bombs if we didn't try like I am Not
sure yeah
but the proofs are quite brittle so I'm
not sure whether both of them we can go
okay so let me just conclude and say
like I just introduced your diversity
measure which builds based on spectral
properties of national vectors
associated with D items and for
cardinality constraint I would want to
say basically we understand how well
these problems can be solved both from a
convex programming approach and as well
a combinatorial algorithms work and we
kind of understand to significant extent
how well they work for more general
constraints of partition and metric
constraints I must mention all of these
algorithms I said they are actually non
algorithmic although I gave algorithm
like I only analyzed this expected value
and these are exponential kind of bounds
and the second one is anyway completely
non algorithmic so these are not out of
make approaches but what they show is
the be convex program will get you a
number which is close to optimum so I
can estimate the value of the problem
but actually cannot find the solution
efficiently right now which is quite I
would say unsatisfactory or like
interesting depending on how you
for more sub like yeah so it is but it's
a very natural open problem how to
actually get algorithm with these
results into algorithms any questions
comments objections so you send it next
amaizing the determinant is a difficult
problem I mean it's convex and where if
you maximize the logo of the debt some
simple constraints like non negativity
and the summation equal okay you can
maximize the log that yes that's what
you do finally yes yeah yeah you can
actually do it but still like it runs
into numerical issues very quickly and
so on yeah yep yeah like we could eat
the box out like I'm not saying but it
takes some time significant time once
your matrices go by down about 50 by 50
and so on
it wasn't quite like a bit like they'd
be big much longer than comparing to
let's say we run local search algorithms
and so on pretty fast as well right yeah
of course you can try to even do first
order methods and so on people have even
try to work that out how well they work
and so on but their convergence is not
that great achillion practically
if you're trying to maximize at least
eigenvalue do you know that local search
fails even under further assumption like
the vector learn to walk like so local
source or these kind of arguments only
work for cardinality constraints all
right not for meat right just like a for
generator for Karnataka chainsaw
yes oh yeah okay so even for the trace
which I kind of skipped over I I so
they're also the vectors that the local
search only works at Lee as long as the
vectors are small I'm not too long
possibly like it can only work when the
vectors are small in at least in for the
trace objective we can actually do a
simple pre-processing if the vector so
long we can actually shorten them
without changing the objective too much
so you can make the vector small and
then do locus or so you can actually
drawn local search by doing a simple
pre-processing about the jaw for we
tried a bit we didn't really have a
clarity either this way or that way
I guess from locum so much if you do the
biggest improvement you can show that
the number of iterations is the number
of local improvements is its small so
it's of course the local improvements
like it's all problems with almost all
know versus algorithm so that's you will
not be able to give a polynomial bomb
but then you just do a simple
approximate local search I'll only make
a improvement if my improvement is large
enough and then the same proves goes
through you and forward you would want
to get that local optimum
you could say that like you're looking
to cardinality constraints solution then
there will be a swamp correct yes yeah
correct by large the objectives are not
linear but yes but there is clearly so
one thing I did not mention in this
class at least for the determinant once
you go to logged it actually that's you
can think of it as a set function as
well or the bit set you pick is that's
actually a submodular function and
there's been a lot of work on maximizing
some other function subject to carnality
and metroid constraints which use
similar arguments that kind of yes local
search arguments that you are suggesting
many of those arguments don't directly
apply over here because our when you
take the log the function is not
necessarily non-negative actually it can
even what minus infinity depending on
which factors you pick because the
determinant could be zero but yeah but
okay I haven't talked so hard on it but
that's a interesting thought yes because
those are the kind of arguments you use
for local source for maximizing some
other functions
[Applause]